everyone I'm Jenny direct oh and this is
lauren zima it is the collaboration
you've been waiting for daily denny and
spilling the royalty live here and for a
very good reason because if you can
believe it
we were actually over a little over a
week until the Royal Wedding and
Lauren's gonna be on the ground Lauren
you're gonna be in London
I'm gonna be in London soon we are
taking off tomorrow I'm not stressed at
all are you packed no now she's got a
lot to do but we are here to bring you
guys everything you need to know about
the wedding like I said Lauren and our
team of et correspondents broadcast
online social work they're gonna be on
the ground bringing you everything you
need to know about Prince Harry and
Meghan Margot it's a big deal
the fact that he is marrying an American
girl is why us Americans I think are
really excited I mean today is about you
and I and our different franchises
coming together but this wedding is
about two countries coming together guys
I mean what a moment it really is I'm so
excited because we've been talking about
this with you guys so much but an
American princess this means not only
America and Britain coming together for
this exciting Hollywood meets royalty
wedding but this is all about the
monarchy moving forward
Meghan Markel is of mixed-race Megan
Markel is a divorcee Megan Markel is a
couple years older than Harry this is
new for the Queen you guys the Queen is
they're having a little sip of her
Chardonnay and she said okay here you go
be happy I love it that's why I'm so
excited about this because they're
shaking up the monarchy folks lately
right and if you know Prince Harry and
the Royals then you know that he's
always kind of marched to the beat of
his own drum and now he found him a
really amazing woman but you're right
who has defied expectations of like what
it means to marry into the royal family
you know yeah which is awesome and we
already know that they're shaking of the
monarchy and we already know this
wedding is gonna be much much different
than William and Kate's yes so in so
many ways which is also really exciting
so of course we are going to England for
the wedding but you guys while Will and
Kate got married in London this wedding
is in Windsor Windsor England at Windsor
Castle an adorable little English
countryside right yes imagine that we're
going to Harry and Megan and the royal
family is country home for this wedding
and the big difference is because will
Prince William he's in line to be king
and Prince Harry not so much which is
why it's always been okay for Prince
Harry to be this rule breaker to have a
little more fun than will willing Kate
are more buttoned up you even see it in
the way that Harry and Megan interact
with each other they called hands they
touch each other will it Kate are much
more refined and they really give us
that kiss on the balcony I got married
we got one we got one yeah I was like
mate I think he forced her to do that
second one but with Harriet Megan maybe
we'll get a dip or something but yeah so
will is in line to be king which meant
that his wedding was a state affair so
it was in London thousands in attendance
world leaders in attendance at this
wedding you know people were wondering
are the Obamas going to come because
Harry and is actually pretty good
friends with Michelle Obama with Barack
you know such power but they have said
no you know this is not gonna be about
that because first of all if you invite
one world leader you got in vitam I
can't offend anyone and they don't want
to do that this wedding is much more
intimate it's much more about friends I
actually talked to and you can check it
out on spilling the royalty and on et
online.com I talked to Julie Montagu who
is a countess a future contest and she
really knows people like in this world
going to this wedding and she said
everything she's hearing is it's much
more just friends invited and she also
says that everybody is so excited for
the monarchy to be moving forward
because not only is it about time but
the monarchy is good for Britain's
tourism you know who they're the royal
so she says look the monarchy has to
innovate has to take a new step and be
interesting and Meghan's giving it this
fresh little facelift and we need that
so it's gonna be a much more intimate
wedding English countryside right um I
also heard because of the venue we won't
get that big balcony wave that we got
from William and Kate because of course
Westminster Abbey and Buckingham Palace
it's meant for that the parade of people
the waves the kiss we won't get them on
a balcony so hopefully we will get that
dip we're somewhere on the hill yeah
altar we will get at what's called the
Long Walk where they literally will in
Kate did this too they literally get
into a carriage and this happens after
the ceremony itself and they're just
paraded around for all to see like the
beautiful you know bridge British
English trophies that they are for all
of us we just want to look at it that's
how I want to get married let's talk a
little bit about the guest list because
you said it's not a state wedding snow
local leaders know Obama's but making us
some famous friends oh yeah yes that's
what we love is Meghan Marcos bringing
in a little of that Hollywood crowd of
course probably some of her suits
co-stars people she's gotten really
close with over the many years of
filming that show Priyanka Chopra who
girl can't hide that she's gonna be
there Ryan she's trying all are though
that's the thing everyone's playing so
cool thank you everybody's really on
edge about that I mean so I've recently
interviewed and again this is gonna be
up on our YouTube channel and some of
it's already up but Spencer Barnes did
makeup for Megan for years he's a
celebrity makeup artist as Julianne
Hough and a bunch of other people and
then Michael sparks who is a celebrity
hairstylist literally did Megan's hair
for ten years she used to fly from
Toronto to Los Angeles just for him to
cut her hair so check him out in Malibu
this guy knows he's doing good but they
have both said look they knew Megan for
years and they haven't even really heard
from her and nobody's offended by that
they understand she basically got
transported into this whole other world
I mean had to delete her Instagram all
these things had to shut it down but
they're like look we kind of hope that
when this royal wedding madness goes
down a little bit we can hear from her
again or Megan back but yeah she got new
cell phone numbers she changed emails
and she had to probably not only because
she's getting into the royal family and
it's a whole other level of fame but
probably security yeah so I think that
while it is a wedding of friends it
really is even on Megan's side only
those most intimate intimate of friends
her long-term longtime best friend from
college we think is gonna be there and
be in the wedding party but Hollywood
wives were also gonna see Serena
Williams they're close friends close
friends yes I do know it's gonna be
there you mentioned Priyanka Chopra and
she has been trying to stay as Koya
possible about whether or not she'll be
attending the wedding of course she has
been busy promoting Quantico the new
season so everyone knows she's friends
with Meghan that we've been asking her
and of course we asked her to watch her
watch her play coy watch her answer we
we bring up the Royal Wedding when
attending a high-profile British wedding
would you wear a fascinator
because Kate Middleton's wedding was all
about the fascinators so we love your
style we're curious as to what kind of
style that you're gonna go you know
hypothetically British sure in a
highbrow
yeah I may or may not be going to right
right I don't know I haven't thought
about it because the hypothetical
wedding isn't coming to my my thing of
things but yeah maybe I would yeah bring
it back something chic like a chic fad I
feel like you would rock that so hard I
think it might be cool I feel like she'd
get it she could have given us a little
more we would have been okay with it
it's like nice try though nice try your
fascinator Priyanka oh my gosh by the
way guys also check out my interview
blinis green who is british but has been
making fascinators and hats here in the
US for 30 years she's made hats for
Taylor Swift for Kerry Washington on
scandal if you were ever that iconic
white hat that was Miss Louise green and
she is making hats for several people
attending the Royal Wedding cluding
Lauren you got to write oh I can't love
it yeah so check her out check out that
interview and she talks about all the
different requirements it is so specific
how you have to be with the sizing of
these hats and everything I love it but
like I've really fallen in love with hat
you know we actually will be going over
that next week during daily Denny we're
gonna we're gonna go over the 8 things
you have to wear at a royal wedding yes
oh it's more than just a hat oh yeah
there's many spis that April were just
breaking it down what he would wear to a
royal wedding okay so Meghan's co-star
in suits
Patrick Jay Adams they actually got
married at the end of the lot last
season they're no longer gonna be on the
show anymore but we did talk to Patrick
who also neither confirmed nor denied
whether or not he was going the royal
wedding but we asked him what he would
buy Meghan and Harry as a wedding gift
take a look okay
now what will you get them as a royal
couple if you go to the wedding or not
we send like a toaster we're trying to
choose between like a blender or bread
maker
you know that's something classy like
take a limb buy a Vitamix
they don't have one uh no dancing yeah
she's gonna need a Vitamix yeah she's in
a room by the Vitamix that's exactly
what Harry and Megan mean honestly I
have a Vitamix put that on your registry
guys it's worth it those blenders last
forever
and we know Megan loves her health
that's true and so does Harry okay I
stand corrected
I don't have one so I would have known
but by the way Harry only we have
learned this from sources guys megan has
made harry more healthy which I love
I mean Brits love them lived in London
for a while they left a party they love
to have a little cocktail megan has
gotten Harry on some green juices oh
she's really good yes I love that she
did roast him a chicken the night he
proposed a nice lean white meat chicken
chicken and he didn't know any that's so
romantic
uh let's talk about this longtime rumor
that the Spice Girls are performing at
the royal wedding they'll be kind of
spilled the beans when she was appeared
on the reel ah you know what she's also
started to backtrack a little bit you
you know what I mean so the Spice Girls
are rumoured to be performing because
that's what Mel B said and then we
talked to her at the kickoff event for
America's Got Talent where you know what
I'm gonna let the camera Madison do the
work take a look speaking of being back
in style a little bit well I'll talk
about the Spice Girls yeah these days
you kind of like drop the hint that
potentially before for me at the Royal
Wedding
you took you craved like a massive fire
stir well no what's the update on them
we signed to Simon full of the original
Spice Girls manager we signed to him a
few months ago okay you were a tiny baby
with when we went on tour and my angel
kind of missed out on that my
ten-year-old my six-year-old is like are
you really a Spice Girl is that really
you because I've got some pictures up of
me holding you in the recording studio I
went through the whole tour thing I had
the best part my sisters came in a
little bit you actually have some
memories memories ending are you gonna
get a chance to do it again at their
wedding we will be doing stuff this year
will better oh yes
perfect camera for doing that lien that
leave it was well also she was going
this yeah I'm glad cameras like are you
gonna come do it again at the Royal I
think that she may be maybe regret
saying everything she said I think so to
actually talked to the ladies of the
real at the Daytime Emmys about that
moment cuz it totally went viral
obviously Spice Girls performing at the
Royal Wedding would make headlines and
the ladies of the real told me that she
reamed them she was just like look what
you guys made me do you know but they
had to take it as fact because the way
she was acting I mean we all watch the
clip if you haven't go to our YouTube
channel in et online.com we have that
moment I think if we look at Megan's age
Megan grew up on the Spice Girls harry's
known them for years now sure I mean why
not take advantage of that moment and at
a willing Kate's wedding I mean Ellie
Goulding performs there they got it had
a blow it out of the water listen if
it's not at the ceremony that the
performing it could be at one of these
two receptions folks there's two
receptions like what are they so
basically and we kind of love this and
think that maybe we should implement it
across weddings I mean you know how
maybe at a wedding you think oh I really
want to get down but like grandma still
here so like I gotta wait for her to go
to bed this is brilliant what they're
doing reception number one is earlier in
the day it is a more refined it is a
wider amount of guests who are gonna be
there and it's more chill reception
number two that's over at a smaller
venue that is something Prince Charles
is throwing just for Harry and Megan and
that's where the real party is gonna
happen later in the yes I mean the
bigger party the smaller number of
people and that's the thing is I'm sure
cellphones will be checked at the door
I'm sure it will be a situation where
they can actually just cut loose and
enjoy themselves because up until that
moment they will have been on camera on
display for the whole world to see the
whole time I mean remember with Will and
Kate's wedding I mean the whole ceremony
is filmed in broadcast you know so
imagine if you're already that nervous
and then you think millions of people
are watching you they're gonna want to
have a glass of champagne later Harry
would he would no he would not want to
broadcast his reception his party I have
a feeling he's gonna have the most fun
at that thing oh he mentions a smaller
groups all know sooo mean more friends
yeah
younger people yes I know that our royal
expert heating Nicholls expects that not
only will that be the real party there's
gonna be some midnight snack we gotta
bust out the munchies some chips as they
say fries no chips what if that was the
American part of the of the nights like
we got some cheeseburgers and fries
incorporate yeah no guys that's all the
time we have for today but we are
sending off flooring to London she's got
to pack you had your hat so do the rest
I got my hats and a hat box that's right
didn't even know this before we go I
know you guys are excited Sarah from
Facebook is saying she's so excited for
the wedding can't wait to see Megan's
dress neither can we we know it's gonna
be gorgeous no matter what Edward from
Facebook this wedding will be the event
of the century I am waking up early to
watch Harry and Megan make history
because let's not forget guys England is
eight hours ahead but we gon be in here
so we easy online teams coming in at
1:00 in the morning just coverage goin
for you guys in fact you guys starting
next week all next week leading up into
the Royal Wedding we are doing daily
denne live including stuff from the
ground from lorenz
and also everything you need to know
about the wedding you guys in Megan's
Pass Harry's past relationships how to
throw a viewing party all that fun for
you guys starting next week live here at
the daily Denny thanks so much for
watching Lauren thanks for all the yes
oh my gosh and if I can tease you guys
we know you love Meghan style like Sarah
was saying so excited for the dress we
are so all over that we are gonna have
pieces going up with Meghan's favorite
hair and beauty products and makeup
products yes we found all this for you
guys and when I'm in England I'm gonna
be talking to Princess Diana's wedding
dress designer ring designer because we
got to give the love to Diana she was an
icon can you tell it's royal wedding hey
guys thanks so much for watching and
we'll see you tomorrow with a brand new
daily Demi
[Music]